[Music]  Kanye Drake and Trebek started from the  bottom now we're here started from the  bottom now the whole team here they mad  they ain't famous they mad they still  nameless but we still hood-famous yeah  we still hood-famous jeopardy host Alex  Trebek epicly quoted the rappers on a  recent episode this as Drake finally  sounds off on Kanye West Kanye called  out Drake wall on the st. Pablo to her  last year just before he was  hospitalized I think he's exhausted now  Drake is responding to the disc telling  beats 1 radio this you know I'm not  really sure what he's referring to half  the time you know when i hear that I  just like you know I just distanced  myself from it like all right you know  if that's what it is you know I don't  really even understand the point you're  trying to make but you know whatever it  is that you're going through I you know  I accept it I don't respect it at all  and you know I just go and continue  working on my own day